so today we are going to focus on
special ideas and we are going to talk
about alkyne idea we are going to talk
about by clinic idea and pass key idea
who knows who was Alexander Alekhine
raise your hand who hurt this name a
John what can you tell us about
Alexander Alekhine let us say first of
all that he was the world champion
Alexander Alekhine
and who knows what number number four
was Alexander Alekhine so he was the
world champion and it speaks for himself
that his ideas that that's why we're
still using his ideas right so once we
get closer to the position that in which
we can use his ideas I will explain more
so let us start with the opening so
night of 3 D 5 C 4 and D for so who
knows the name of this opening raise
your hands
go ahead this is Slav Club defense night
of 6 and 93 so exactly Slav defense to
catch it laughs clever Slav Club SL AV
and right top so Catalan is with g3 when
the pawn goes from g2 g3 and another
pawn structure with blacks
so then is exactly self-defense 9b d7 ok
let us stop at this point
Elkind created the idea that in this
type of positions when the construction
is undefined when the point is on d5 and
on c6 and white can take or reverse
maybe black so with the same point
structure can take on d5 here
and then you will be forced to take with
the pawn from c6 to d5 and unite is on
d7 already then it's not really good so
it's better when the construction is
defined and CSS d5 CSD file to develop
your Knight to c6 instead of d7 that was
his idea so we will see why that works
so takes takes and now you see the night
on d7 is not that active as if the
knight was on c6 do you agree with me so
that's why when you play with white
these positions raise your hands who
please
d poor one so the rest play E for right
sit again okay well but I think that for
chess education that that will be good
to know so if you play d4 and you go to
the slot variations note that if your
opponent develops the Knight to d7 you
can just take on d5 and then the knight
and the seven will be doing nothing it
will be less active Bishop before so
this is still opening going on - just
normal development h3 because if the
knight most to h5 we want to save the
bishop product from a4 did you get it
the h3 and v5 castle we should be seven
and now a four why do we play a four who
has any ideas Jason what do you think
why do I play a four
right we want do we want to undermine
the pawn chain and the best idea how you
can undermine the pawn chain is from the
from the infrared beginning
you cannot undermine from a six because
we didn't have to have this additional
file right so that's why you undermine
it from a form then be for what moves
are possible here
I cut a nice night to eat tomb Keti
night to be one or a two so basically we
have three moves what do you think what
was the next month say it again
Knight to e2 or nine to eight okay that
that's a good idea which is possible
here so Knight can move to a to the
knight moves to c1 and to be stream they
need to show it to you or your
calculated good in the game a white
plate Knight to e2
well basically you save the same idea
you can still move to c1 + 2 B 3 but
Knight is closer to the center rook c8
this is logical I guess when we have the
open file what do we do with this file
we want to control that's why black
controls a5 a5 is the move which I will
ask you what did the idea behind f5 this
is first idea in what is second raise
your hands if you have in Quetta it
leaves very good and one more in a dias
Jason
it controls b6 so do you remember the
beginning of our conversation when we
said that the 927 will not be that
well-developed and after playing a five
so a sketchy said we'll leave the point
on before let us say is almost isolated
because the pawn on e6 is too far is
going to it cannot protect then Jason
you said that we control be seized and
not allow the night from d7 to move to
be six and band moved to c4 also what
else after playing a five what else do
Adam we did not allow black to move a
file by himself into portal before and
to control more space castle 91 so you
see this idea that the night is going to
be three one time a rock c6 and Knight
to b3 so basically we have the entire
control of the Queen side without even
putting the rooks on the C file right so
we our Bishop control c4 c2 the night
control c5 the point control c5 the
point from a five controls b6 so we
control the entire site and what can you
tell me about the bishop on b7
is it good enough John what do you think
about the bishop
it's like a pawn right just it's not
participating in Queen eight what is
black want to do after Queen a like
future future plan
assume
lack of somehow got to get that
correct
so defy opponent well from the first of
you you have the opinion that what is
black doing the bishop is on b7 the
queen goes to a aid and they all a stack
with a pawn on d5
so first idea is to open c8 for another
rook and like another idea maybe the
situation will happen that black will be
able to open the diagonal so to put it
apart from a 6 to e5 somehow and open
this diagonal of course it's not easy
but behind a queen a there are two ideas
95 so white doesn't want black to move
e5 in no way no way you want to open
that diagonal Knight takes bishop takes
and then f6 from the now like from this
standpoint here think that well maybe a
black will manage to move the pontiff -
open the position Bishop a4 let's
calculate if black plays d5 is it good
or will it change anything and how will
you react so now this is the assignment
for you
write me the white smooth you have
papers you have pencils write down the
the move so the main lines that you
wrote were d4 x g5 f XE v and bishop AXA
v i think this is the simplest way so d4
is impossible because the knight is
hanging on e4 the other variation that
you wrote was Bishop h2 which also had
the right to exist
because you got the idea you want it
didn't want to open the diagonal right
when Bishop is goes to H tomb and point
takes and D for the 1974 and the bishop
on b7 the Queen on a a there just
talk the other variation that I liked
also it was Bishop takes e4 so what did
the idea eight-five cannot take on f4
because Bishop takes on d5 they get the
idea once you take on e4 you can take on
e5 and whoa what did we get from this
variation so we got that we still block
the diagonal but we got the extra pawn
and we opened the square for the for the
night so the knife from b3 can move to
d4 so that means e five is a bad move f5
happened in the game f3 let's get rid of
this annoying night that controls that
many squares Knight return back to f6
and then g4 look at this move instead of
trying to play on the C file
we're definitely black
for now has certain fresh like to drink
control with their work on c6 and then
bring the rook to see eight white
mention that while the queen is on a 8
the bishop on b7 Ruka somewhere with C 6
why don't we start the attack on the
King side 927 Blair doesn't want to take
the pawn on g4 because if pontus on g4
with which point are going to take F or
each
as in I think both taken with both bonds
is good you can take with each point it
will be closer to the center II will
still control efore and you will have
h-file to attack so King to g2 Andrew to
h1 next taking with f1 this is another
story from a pawn structure is its
weaker because you separate the pawns
and you create more point islands but
from the tactical point of view you are
going to place your Bishop on e5 you're
going to double the rooks in the F file
and then play g5 black has the weakness
on e6 so this was also possible
that's why black decided not to move
learner to make that move and taken to
foreign play Knight to d7 rook to c1
again wide please on both sides he
checked black where the black is going
to take on g4 and if black - kanji fwah
we're always going Y to play at him if
black took on g4 in this position where
was white going to play what do you
think so in the Kings side since black
stepped away with the Knight to d7 we
can transfer our forces to the Queen
side because on the King side everything
is fine but we do not want to touch
anything here who want to force black to
start exchanges first rook takes in c1
rook takes on c1 1 takes on g4 Brooks is
7 look at this
tactics black black took on g4 and
expect it white to take on g4 back but
instead white played rook c7 attacking
the d7 all night and after d7 the bishop
on e7 is hanging one takes Queen take so
it leads black things well we have one
extra pawn maybe it will help us
but it didn't really help so bishop
moves back to c8 look at blacks position
it's inactive although almost all the
pieces are inactive but you have to be
careful once you sacrifice the the pawn
was sacrificing the point this is the
minimum what you can sacrifice am i
right
however once you sacrifice the point you
have to be careful and you have to be
responsible for that sacrifice and
therefore you have to be very active
Queen to h5 attackin h7 is hanging what
will be your next move right down okay
let's go forward and see what happens in
the game who are thinking about this
move right raise your hands one two
three four five six seven okay not bad
what are the rest of the team was
reviewing what were you reviewing tell
me the other moves John Quin g5j s'en
what
Bishop takes h7 Queen h4 but Bishop h7
looks so natural right if Knight takes
what are the next 12 kitty
but you wrote this Bishop h7 okay so if
Knight takes on h7 what in the next
MOBAs in Luke takes e7 king to h8 what
do we do next
it's not writing assignment just raise
it raise your hands and tell me what
you're going to do next I see Queen to
h4 correct bishop d8 okay it's time to
sacrifice roaches 7 right this is this
move that comes to our mind first
go ahead Jason your move what's next
what do I do next how can we check mate
because we sacrifice the rook hmm raise
your hands just everybody I want
everybody to participate when it's Lupin
in this clause queen inch six good Kim
to f7 catty
first Bishop to d6 y Queen to g6 will be
the next mode but first you have to take
East 7 under control otherwise after
Queen to g6 as in what will be black
smooth King qt7 corrupt and then the
King moves further and further to d7 and
runs to the Queen side but we're not
interested in that so that's why bishop
goes to d6 right the roof goes to g8
Chuck Bishop takes King takes Chuck
any ideas
take the bishop assume you're right if
you do not see the mate right right away
with tamp you take the material back and
you have one extra pawn right now you're
attacking you're close to wheeling go
into six black tries to awake
Chuck
who wants to tell the nest woof winches
seven correct next move Bishop f4 first
24 then qh6
and then again you have to give the
check back
Kanaka returns back so after Bishop of
four we want to play Queen h6 and I do
not see any defense how did you like the
game so from the very beginning the
mistake was made when white played the
Knight to d7 right then it was the rush
and white reacted correctly to 25 and
that night basically spoiled many things
in blacks development right so imagine
the night instead of d7 on c6 the
situation will be completely different
good let's go to the next game to the
next position
this is puskás idea this this will be a
writing assignment so why to play and
write me your move just one move I need
from you after that and what I will
explain us Paskus idea
almost everybody wrote g4 I got your
idea that that's really good that you
have let you you got that idea you
wanted to prevent the knife from going
to f5 right
you wanted to extend the control another
move was Bishop to c5 which was also
good and Bishop g7 which I think doesn't
make any sense because you your Bishop
is too strong now getting closer to
Spartacus idea by the way the good
question do you know Boris Spassky have
you heard about him caite what do you
know about versace
right speaking about Boris Spassky if
you want you can go to the chess whole
theme and they have well just an amazing
exhibition of Jaqueline Patti Gorski who
was a great organizer of the grandmaster
tournament in California and she was she
was really close to become a United
States Champion but she well she never
got the title but she participated in
the championships many times and Boris
Spassky played against Bobby Fischer and
she was also there at those events so
you can go there and just see him and
see the picture of Boris Spassky and
actually you can see his real score
sheet like I mean handwriting how she
was writing okay but we're going to
talking about different story the move
that I'm going to show you is Bishop e7
that was spassky's idea so you block the
file when you have two rooks opposing
each other and you want to double the
rooks on the on that file so in this
concrete situation we want to double the
rooks on the a file am i right but
without moving the bishop to a stand and
how can we double the rooks we can't
right how can we Katie do you have any
idea how can we double the rules without
playing Bishop e7
right so we can take when an a8 rook
takes on aid then we can play root K 1
but still this doesn't help us it's just
trading the pieces so after Bishop is 7
what happens you can double the rooks
you can though the next move will be
rookie 6 then rook a 1 and you'll read
here have enough pieces there but of
course be careful when your opponent can
attack the bishop if the rook wasn't
enough 8 but was on c8 then your point
could have played rooks e7 attacking the
bishop so when you play this type of
positions so knight move to f5 our move
rookie six loop protects the pawn rook
e1 you see how easy we doubled the roofs
just knowing days maneuver if five the
bishop returns back to c5 and then after
this black has to do something with this
efile he cannot stay on the a file
anymore so he can either trade on a6 or
step to b8 so for example if he trades
on a six then you take back on a6 a
check in c6 pawn and the rook is
attached to the pawn and the knight
cannot protect the pawn because the
Bishop on c5 that bishop that you guys
wanted to trade no way we're going to
trade this Bishop is he's so strong the
bishop controls c7 d6 d4 what I'm going
to do now you're going to bring your
King and fonts step by step right okay
we're done with this position go into
the next one
against Paskus idea will be presented
here but this is a game so we will start
with the opening again what is the name
of this opening well ready so it
Slav good job and G stream so g3 is one
of the deviations here you can go to
soup this is not Catalan Catalan is
different structure usually the ponies
urgency six the ponies on e6 and then
cattle AMPA happens when the points on
CC this is love which is read in sloth
defense Bishop a5 Knight c3 Queen b3
Queen b6 another typical idea when you
have this opposition of the Queen's do
not be afraid in this type of positions
to play c5 from from one standpoint you
would say well while we're going to
double the points on the B file so the
Queen takes and then we have this a a to
be a bishop one so b3 b2 points are
doubled why do we have to do that who
knows the answer get here what do you
think why is it worse of double on the
pawns what so from one point of view
it's bad to have double bows but in
these concrete situation we're talking
about this position why did we go for
that who knows John
correct so thanks to this exchange of
Queens we opened up the rook and now the
route controls a file what are going to
do with this double pawns we're going to
push the pole from b3 to be 5 and then
we're going to get rid of this pawn if
black plays a 6 then well you will see
it later in the game so I'm not going to
explain it right now you will see it
Knight to e4 again typical nitrogen for
attacking the bishop what is our next
move as in before correct F scream
you see how many maneuvers were doing
the position is closed and you have time
with white to transfer your pieces so
the main battle is going to happen in
the center and on the Queen side right
that's why we're bringing our pieces to
the center Knight to the stream it's in
that Bishop on b2 is do nothing but we
can always try to bring the air to the
bishop by playing c4 so a5 and this
position in this game Blanc decided to
play aggressively on the Queen side not
to play a six and just wait so black
played a5 trying to open up the a file
and fight for it can get can get fate so
now we have the position again the
position of two rooks right look on a8
rook on a1 and in my opinion white is
better you can defend black but I will
tell you why I think white is better so
first of all look at this pawn structure
the Poland b7 is is not protected by any
other pawn and the v6 is controlled by
c-51 then you're going to push if for
maybe one day or at least if you're
going to fight for the a file most
likely that you will be able to use
whose rule whose idea baskis idea so we
will see it later b5 so the Queen side
is blocked and only a file is open so
basically all the fight is going to be
held on the a file you take how do we
call it everybody knows I'm by son good
now it takes and be 695 so that was the
idea why would two can be six right
because the knight was already on d3 if
Bishop takes on this tree what will be
next
Bishop takes in this room first
right as him your rights of b7 that that
was the Shred the night T to convey six
and night went to c5 Bishop e7 Bishop a6
attacking the rook rook c7 let's stop
here assume tell me about this position
about Bishop to a6 spot kiss idea right
what does it allow us to do
Bishop a6 no we're not going to be 7
we're going to double the rooks so that
is our idea ro K 5 or K 1 so now black
can do nothing to change the situation
the a file because the bishop separates
the rooks but ah
moreover look at the before pawn and the
rook on a5 the rook is protected by the
pawn that is another provost position of
this moved Bishop e6 so why it moved the
bishop to aces because he understood
that before pawn would would have
protected the rook on a 5 and then the
roof from a1 so rougarou 5 has good
protection that's why your Bishop can be
free right your bishop can freely move
to be 7 or turn back some maneuvers and
look at this.look Bishop b5 finally
black made a mistake
and Bishop takes on six there is it
because black would under the pressure
it was really hard to play all the game
on the limited area with the limited
space and once you give your opponent to
make a mistake when everything is set up
correct in your position well you have a
good percentage that he would he'll make
that mistake rook takes only five knight
returns back to c8 and this is just a
matter of time when I go to win this
game and one more example this is about
Phoenix idea so but Phoenix idea a
little bit different but again do you
know who is Michael between ik with the
world champion to the things we have the
first two examples with world champions
I think that was either to to guess and
you see that being a world champion that
means something since we use the ideas
after so many years so let's go through
the opening quicker this is another
opening then how do we call it Queens
gambit declined right 9b d7 but here
this is not about 9:57 it's about the
other story I will tell you later when
we counter that idea so it's three c6
Bishop distri I'm just typical Queens
gambit declined normal development efore
the main idea if you do not play so did
I play this lines so keep in mind that
is three two if for for example if you
play with black you should know that for
both sides for black the ID is 65 for
white is three for now it takes Knight
takes Bishop takes in 27 so black is
going to play either c5 or if I
go into it too and Bishop f4 did you
before trying to trade the bishops
otherwise well right now named g5 is not
possible but I'm thinking about doing do
you know this idea sacrifice of the
bishop bishop h7 then 95 keep that in
mind we cannot play this right away
because of the night most to f6 Knight
protects this h7 but keep it keep that
in mind that this is possible maybe you
will be able to catch one of your
opponents one day so Bishop a4 bishop of
for Queen takes up for Andrew g1 we are
placing the pieces in the center and the
main point here is D for D for controls
be 5 D for control c5 and and of course
the Bishop the lion quad Bishop on the
diagonal b1 h7 this is one of our major
pieces here I mean major attacking
pieces
so Ruby 8 what did the Gulf Ruby it John
OMB one day b5 so just do not stay on
this diagonal where the bishop is wrote
the two we're going to double the rooks
negative six attacking the bishop are we
going to trade the bishop or we're going
to run away as in run away we need that
guy Queen c7 Rudy one so basically it's
simple right we created an idea we're
going to play in the central D file we
know the main pieces that we use here in
c5 like a very very important moment
because after c5 you have to define what
you're going to do either you're opening
the file or you trade the opponent just
keep the pawn on d4 what do you think
what are we going to do here
are we going to put the pawn to d5 get
it what do you think you don't think so
why don't you think so
so let's calculate the line so d5 exd5
cxd five and then what about the
blacksmith now knife cannot take because
root rook will take the pawn do you see
so d5 take take you cannot take with the
night you see because the rook takes so
if take take move Queen d6 well Fabia
the mouth then b5 we do not have dark
squared bishop so it will be really hard
to get rid of the queen or d6
what's the best blocker of the pawn
do you know the night the queen is not
the best but here it works what it would
take on c5 Queen takes on c5 we
controlled e-file I think it's also a
good idea but this is the moment where
we are going to talk about but vinick's
idea
so michael between ik said that when you
have the open file in the center and you
really want to get that file one of the
possibilities is trading and here in
this position trading of Queens
unexpectedly absolutely unexpectedly
Queen ephod we calculated d5 we
calculated c5 at capturing on c5 even
not reacted on c5 but Queen e5 so the
idea is we are going to open the file
with Temple by trade in the Queens
because black legs development
Queen takes because Queen has to take
the rukon v8 is hanging otherwise you
take with the pawn of course because we
interested in opening the file and the
knight moves back did it work for us
trade in for opening the file so after
that nine moves to g5 they taken h7 and
then rotate so you are going to crash
your opponent because he doesn't have
development you're just trying to
activate the pieces but look at f6
square that the night goes to f6 and d6
square they're so weak I think later
let's return back to this position of
the 95
if h6 happens how can we play here
correct and what happens we have will
have one extra exchange right good good
job as in the g6 through d8 b5 take 97
94 95 write me your next move like a
couple of moves one move it will it
won't be enough just a couple of most
your idea 96 rising hands heralded move
okay good job so actually the majority
saw that move King g7 Katie your line no
and my you rhodonite h7 right but 95 is
stronger so instead what happens if I
take on f6 with the night and Wis right
and checkmate so I play here
John your next move
you have one extra pawn you can trade
you can play Ruby 7 pin in the bishop so
a7 will be hanging so if Bishop move
somewhere you can take on a 7 so let's
let's go with the game notation so King
g7 rook took and Knight took on d5 took
Bishop e6 what's your next 12 assume
rook c5 ism Bishop takes then B string
how do you like it
King yes
trapped king get King f1 King the 7
kinky one a six of course black wants to
save his bishop take rook takes came to
this tree and then King comes to be 2
and what are you going to do next
let me play with black Katie you move
Brooksie for I take that doesn't work so
that's why let's think John any ideas
King bee - right ok play f6 for example
Adam
Jason
what do you have to do here how are you
going to win that bishop you need to
bring the rook to a one visit the task
and they ruled e1 and rook a1 and you
win the bishop nothing nothing special
so f6 was a bad move instead of f6 I
should have just stayed on one place but
you can you can transfer you can
sacrifice be five but get it in a
different way you can play rook c3 I
take route is ruled e1 roque one so what
did we learn today John what did you
learn from today's lecture so all the
kind ideas with the knight development
spassky's ideas with a double in the
roofs by blocking the file and but
veneks ideas trading the pieces for
opening the file right so three new
ideas that hopefully you will be able to
use in your dream